hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain an american found footage horror
film called the visit
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
two siblings from philadelphia 15 year
old becca and 13 year old tyler
prepare for a five-day visit with their
grandparents while their divorced mother
loretta goes on a cruise with her new
boyfriend
loretta reveals that she has not spoken
to her parents in 15 years after
marrying her high school teacher
of whom her parents disapproved having
never met their grandparents
the teens planned to record a
documentary film about their visit using
a camcorder
at the train station becca and tyler
meet their grandparents for the first
time
whom becca refers to as nana and pop pop
the kids are very happy seeing their
grandparents for the first time
arriving at the house becca is busy
recording all activities with tyler
using her camera
nana is also very happy with the
presence of her grandchildren
tyler and becca get settled into their
room upstairs which used to be their
mothers
so far everything seems very normal
things start out very well
tyler and becca are both given the
freedom to explore
they are having a fun day together
exploring the surroundings
at night grandpa comes into their room
to give them some information
in this house they have to obey some
rules becca and tyler
are instructed to never go into the
basement because it contains toxic mold
and that time is at 9 30 pm after which
they shouldn't leave their room
however that night becca and tyler
couldn't sleep
an hour past curfew becca is hungry so
she ventures downstairs for something to
eat
she intends to take a cake from the
kitchen however to her surprise
she sees nana walking aimlessly and
vomiting all over the house
which frightens her becca immediately
runs into her room
feeling anxious the next day
she questions her grandfather about the
event that happened last night
pop pop insists that nana had a stomach
bug and wasn't feeling well
he then reminds her not to leave their
bedroom after 9 30 p.m
during the day the kids continue to
explore they play hide and seek in a
crawl space underneath the house
tyler hides becca seeks tyler out with
her camera
making her own way into the dimly lit
maze columns however
becca is surprised when she turns and is
confronted by the lunging
animalistic form of nana bounding
towards her in an unnaturally fast gate
she immediately flees trying to escape
before nana can reach her
becca retreats sprawling out of the
crawl space into the safety of sunlight
nana emerges laughing at what she sees
as a joke
a few moments later a doctor named dr
sam comes to their door and asks to talk
to their grandparents
but their grandparents are not home at
the moment as they had just gone for a
walk
he claims that he is from maple shade
the hospital the grandparents volunteer
at
he stops by to check on them and wonders
why they haven't been coming in for the
scheduled shifts
then while their grandparents are still
away tyler decides to investigate what's
in the shed
while vlogging he sneaks inside and
finds in the corner
a pile he gets closer to see what it is
and discovers its used adult diapers
after their grandparents return home pop
pop takes becca and tyler through the
town
he shows the school their mother used to
study at a moment later
however pop pop tells them to leave
because they're being followed
the kids see a man across the street pop
pop runs over and begins to accost the
man
yelling at him becca and todder convince
him to leave the man alone
and pop-pop realizing he's just being
paranoid apologizes to them
that night at 10 47 p.m they hear a
scary sound coming outside their locked
door
the two want to film what's on the other
side so tyler tells becca to open the
door
when the door is open
they see a naked nana clawing at the
door opposite them scratching like a
frantic dog
they immediately shut the door the next
morning
pop pop and nana are outside with
breakfast on the table
nana apologizes because she's got hot
oil over becca's computer webcam
as a result when they are talking to
their mother on skype they aren't able
to show their faces
tyler and becca immediately tells their
mother that their grandparents have been
acting strange these past few days
she reassures them their grandparents
are weird but they're also old
and old people are sometimes cranky
sometimes paranoid
that's just how old people act in the
afternoon
becca approaches her grandmother asking
her to be interviewed
becca interviews nana by asking her warm
up questions
she asks nana what happened 15 years ago
to cause her not to speak to her
daughter
however nana starts going berserk
shaking violently
that night at 10 16 pm they hear a
horrible commotion outside the door
they want to know what nana is doing
this time when they open the door
they see nana running past with both
arms behind her back
rushing past them in both directions
just as she's about to crawl towards the
camera
they shut and lock the door on the
fourth day
another strange thing happens when becca
and tyler see their grandmother staring
into a well
tyler and becca approach the well to try
to figure out what is hidden inside
but all they pull up is water later that
day a neighbor named stacy comes over
telling them their grandparents
volunteered at the hospital when she was
in rehab
and she baked treats to thank them later
that evening
becca is in the living room and hears
nana laughing hysterically
she decides to show what kind of
television show makes her nana laugh
hoping it's the same one her mom loves
but she finds nana rocking in a chair
facing the wall suddenly the grandmother
covered her own face with a shawl
becca also goes into the shed and finds
pop-pop with a rifle in his mouth
due to strange occurrences that keep
happening they decide to set up a hidden
camera in the living room to see exactly
what goes on at night
time passes and they fall asleep in the
living area
the camera records nana opening and
slamming the basement door several times
she picks up the camera and then films
herself going into the kitchen where she
grabs a butcher knife
she makes her way up to the kid's
bedroom and begins pounding at their
door
becca and tyler wake up startled they
can hear nana trying to get in but just
stay still the next morning
they watch the footage and see that nana
was trying to kill them becca tells
tyler that their mom is back from her
vacation that day
so they just have to avoid their
grandparents all day by going out and
pretending to play
becca uses that moment to scrub the oil
off of her webcam
they wait until the grandparents are up
front and they immediately get on skype
the oil has been scrubbed off of the
webcam so their mom can see them now
they quickly tell her that she needs to
come and pick them up right now as their
grandparents are scaring them
tyler films the grandparents from the
window so his mom can see them
the mom is now white-faced and reveals
to both of them that they are not her
parents
which means they have been living with
strangers all week their mom immediately
tries to call
the local police she tells them to get
somewhere safe
but just then the grandparents return a
few hours later
outside the window they see nana and
pop-pop in a heated argument with their
neighbor
stacy they wonder what they are fighting
about
later that night the grandparents
suggest having a board game night
but the kids say they want to record
something outside while the grandparents
figure out the teams
they head for the yard only to see stacy
hanging dead from a tree
pop pop appears and tells them they
already have the teams old versus young
the kids are forced to play yahtzee with
the fake grandparents
becca excuses herself from the game
saying she's got to film something real
quick
tyler who is now left alone begins to
feel strange things
pop pop suddenly walks away from the
table and nana is seen eating cake
unnaturally
the old man returns to the table and
approaches his wife who suddenly freezes
becca goes down to the basement
explaining to the viewer that she thinks
her real grandparents have been trapped
down there
and that's why pop pop told them to stay
away becca begins calling out for the
real nana and pop pop but doesn't hear a
response
in the corner she sees a dumpster and
hurries over to it
inside she sees something from maple
shade which she now learns as a
psychiatric hospital
she also finds a family photo of her
real grandparents
she digs some more into her surprise she
finds the corpses of her real
grandparents
immediately behind her pop pop has
appeared this is where he reveals
everything
he and the woman becca knows his nana
were patients at a nearby mental
hospital where the real nana and pop pop
were regular volunteers
when they told them about their upcoming
visit with their grandchildren
the two imposters decided it would be
fun to experience in their place
so they murdered their real grandparents
and took their place
it is also revealed that fake nana once
had children of her own
therefore a few days ago the grandmother
was seen staring into a well because she
remembered that
35 years ago she deliberately threw her
child into the well
furthermore it is also revealed that
nana experiences something called
sundowning
which is a form of dementia that happens
when the sun sets
that explains why fake nana is often
increasingly confused at nights and
prone to erratic behavior in low
lighting
throughout the movie other folks from
the hospital have been stopping by the
house to check up on their grandparents
but fake grandparents have conspired to
be out for a walk during these visits
after the revelation pop pop grabs becca
and imprisons her in his bedroom with
nana
meanwhile he then starts to
psychologically torment tyler by
smearing his face with his dirty diaper
simultaneously becca continues to be
chased by nana
nana smashes becca's face into the
mirror and pieces of blast shatter all
around them
becca picks up a shard of glasses nana
jumps on top of her clawing at her
becca fatally stabs nana with a glass
shard killing her
she runs into the kitchen and tackles
pop-pop as pop-pop starts to get the
upper hand
tyler attacks him and knocks him to the
floor and repeatedly slams the
refrigerator door onto his head
killing him soon after they hear police
sirens
they immediately run outside to find
their mom and police cars out front
they hug each other and grateful that
they are now safe that's the ending of
the movie the visit
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out
thank you for watching